je festival de cannes des stars à la
pelle des soirées qui s'enchaînent mais
aussi des films a toujours bien reçu par
la critique ou par le public entre les
spectateurs et les réalisateurs la
croisée de vire parfois au jeu de
massacre 1973 la grande bouffe de marco
ferreri est présenté en compétition
l'histoire de quatre amis enfermé tout
un week-end à la campagne qui décident
de manger et boire jusqu'à la mort une
orgie de culinaires et sexuelle qui va
scandaliser la croisette
la même année la maman et la [ __ ] de
jean eustache fait lui aussi couler
beaucoup d'encre un film désenchantée de
3 heures 40 porté par des dialogues crus
et provoquant c'est la douche froide
pour le critique de cinéma gilles jacob
futur président emblématique du festival
je trouve pour paraphraser le
vocabulaire employé par jean eustache
que c'est un film merdique
je trouve que c'est un bon film non
filmée par un nom cinéaste et non joué
par un acteur
huit ans après sa palme d'or pour un
homme et une femme claude lelouch
revient à cannes en 1974 savent pas ce
que toute une ville reçoit un accueil
des plus houleux jugée confuse et trop
ambitieuse par la critique maintenant
monsieur si vous voulez on revoit le
film ensemble tous les deux dans une
salle 106 fleurs et vous écoutez le
texte les intentions et pourquoi on
arrive aux choses en 1987 c'est
l'attribution de la palme d'or qui va
secouer la croisette récompensé pour son
film sous le soleil de satan
maurice pialat répond avec panache au
sifflet dans la salle je ne devais pas
faillir à ma réputation je suis surtout
content ce soir pour tous les cris et
les sifflets que vous m'adressez et
si vous ne m'aimez pas je peux vous dire
que je ne vous aime pas non plus 1997
deux ans après le triomphe de la n
mathieu kassovitz s'offre à nouveau les
honneurs cannois avec assassin un film
coup de poing qui prend pour sujet la
violence que le figaro ne tarde pas à
qualifier de films le plus nul de
l'histoire du cinéma
ces trois projections depuis hier soir
ont provoqué des réactions viscérales le
plus souvent à digne et cinq ans plus
tard sexe violence des vengeances sont
au menu d'irréversible de gaspar noé
l'un des plus grands scandales que le
festival ait connu c'est la protéger de
la violence gratuite
c'est un film qui est lamentable pour
l'édition 2021 tradition oblige la
critique et les spectateurs vont encore
se déchaînent autres
[Musique]